la parole est à christian estrosi ce
monsieur le premier ministre
un cadre d'air france lynché par des
grévistes et des images qui font le tour
du monde
une crise migratoires non maîtrisés
impôts de policiers entre la vie et la
mort pour avoir été sauvagement agressé
par un détenu en permission appartenant
au grand banditisme et radicalisée et en
écho un silence assourdissant de votre
part nous dénonçons avec force ce recul
intolérable de l'autorité de l'état
fruit de trois années de lois laxistes
et permissive et d'impuissance
généralisée que nous dit votre garde des
sceaux suite au drame de ce policier
pour lequel nous avons une pensée pour
lui et tous les siens
un rapport l'idée de faire escorter les
permissionnaires par des policiers les
policiers ont autre chose à faire ils
sont là pour se concentrer sur la
sécurité de nos concitoyens pas pour
tenir compagnie à des prisonniers en
permission
nous dénonçons ce recul de la république
qui signifie le recul de la sécurité et
donc de la liberté pour nos concitoyens
je vous demande monsieur le premier
ministre après l' attaque du thalys où
il s'agissait d'un des cinq mille
individus fichés s c'est-à-dire sûreté
de l'état
tout comme l'était l'agresseur du
policier lundi de donner enfin les
moyens au service de faire la guerre à
ses ennemis de l'intérieur
tout d'abord de placer sous surveillance
électronique avec bracelet tous les
individus faisant l'objet d'une fiche s
sur le territoire français ensuite de ne
plus accorder de permission de sortie
aux individus dangereux qui sont fichés
l'état est dépassé l'état est en
débandade car l'état n'est plus dirigé
êtes-vous enfin décidé à prendre des
initiatives pour que la peur change de
camp
merci la parole est au premier ministre
monsieur le
madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député christian estrosi ce
qui affaiblit l'état ce qui affaiblit la
démocratie ce qui affaiblit les valeurs
de la france et de la république
ce sont les amalgames et vos outrances
sur tous les sujets que vous avez pris
dans un amalgame absurde qui n'est pas
partagée sur l'ensemble des bandes de
cette assemblée
j'en suis convaincu sur la france
nous avons clairement dit les choses
dans le soutien à la direction pour un
plan de redressement de cette entreprise
face à la concurrence mondiale avec un
soutien total et absolu à l'égard de ces
deux cadres et les salariés qui ont été
agressés hier
de ce point de vue là n'avons aucune
leçon et sur ces sujets là à recevoir
nous n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir de
votre part et au contraire chacun
s'honorerait ici dans cette assemblée à
faire preuve d'unité et de rassembler et
de rassemblement pour soutenir la
compagnie nationale sur les questions de
sécurité d' autorité de lutte contre le
terrorisme
monsieur estrosi quand vous étiez au
pouvoir vous avez supprimé plus de 13
mille postes de policiers et de
gendarmes
c'est ce gouvernement c'est cette
majorité qui créera plus de 5000 postes
de policiers et de gendarmes et pour le
service c'est ce gouvernement
quand j'étais ministre de l'intérieur
qui a mené la réforme indispensable
nécessaire
tirant les leçons de toulouse créant la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure mais moi sur la question du
terrorisme
je suis convaincu là aussi d'une chose
c'est seulement l'unité et le
rassemblement de tous comme vous l'avez
démontré le 13 janvier dernier et non
pas pourrir encore une fois derrière
l'extrême droite avait des amalgames
doute aux extrêmes droites qui ne votent
en rien jamais les mesures
nécessaires pour lutter contre le
terrorisme à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat au parlement européen
monsieur estrosi j'ai une conviction et
je me suis exprimé clairement là dessus
la responsabilité elle doit être partagé
par tous y compris par la justice et par
les juges mais j'ai une conviction
opposé en permanence policiers et
magistrats ne mène qu'à affaiblir une
fois de plus l'autorité de l'état et de
la république et monsieur estrosi
monsieur estrosi moi je crois en l'état
je crois dans les rôles des services
publics
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse signaler du
doigt en permanence l'effectif des
fonctionnaires
je ne crois pas que la chienlit soit la
bonne réponse aux problèmes de notre
pays et je crois plus que jamais que
nous avons besoin d'un état et le
service public
vous et vos amis monsieur estrosi avec
nice écrite avec nicolas sarkozy vous
proposer moins de fonctionnaires
c'est-à-dire que vous proposez - deux
policiers
vous proposez moines fonctionnaires vous
proposer moins de gendarmes vous
proposer moins de fonctionnaires ces
délits en moins d'enseignants moins de
services publics c'est ça affaiblir
l'état et enfin monsieur estrosi
cette semaine j'aurais attendu de vous
autre chose que ce discours au moment où
l'autorité de l'état et la solidarité
nationale s'exprime dans les
alpes-maritimes
soyez dignes monsieur estrosi par
rapport à ces événements
la parole gitana